the met is um
you know an organization that's under
the spotlight and as the policing
minister absolutely said what we need
now is authentic leaders who step
forward and lead and we've seen that in
crested dick we've seen that repeatedly
when the met comes under attack we've
seen that yesterday when she read her
statement outside the old bailey and you
could see and i could see that the sheer
emotion that she managed to contain
uh and the the the gritty determination
that she's showing to get this right and
and i know cressida and i know
very senior officers that she's uh
bought into her most senior management
team some of the most talented women in
policing ac louise rolfe ac helen ball
and for us to be having a debate now
about this you know taking the scalp of
of of more women in the context of what
we're talking about is entirely wrong
what we need to be focusing on okay is
what needs to change in policing what
the what policing is as a whole and the
met in particular needs to learn from
this monster and he was a monster
and so that this can never ever happen
again
yeah but her officers her male officers
feel so comfortable that they can
actually share between themselves
homophobic misogynistic comments and
other officers since 2010 hundreds and
hundreds have been investigated only 70
odd have lost their jobs and you know
she is presiding over that doesn't
matter if she's a woman or not she's the
head of the met and this is going on
under her nose
what we found as a former hmi and i led
the report on shining a light on
betrayal
is that we need to stamp out in policing
these misogynistic attitudes this sense
that it's all right to join into banter
which is you know
making fun of women demeaning men women
subverting women away from their kind of
principle activities and we know that
within policing there's been an awful
lot of work done since we published that
report to challenge some of these
attitudes and this is not just about
supporting
male officers and female officers who
speak out against this this is actively
encouraging this to happen and i'm
seeing that happening now in police
forces up and down the land and i know
it's happening to in the met the only
way through this is to address this
issue head-on to not call out the
narrative i i would say that this is a
one-off that this is an aberration wayne
cousins was a monster but we must be
certain that this can never ever happen
again and the debate i think today
should be about looking forward what now
needs to change to make sure that the
trust in policing can be
restored it has been broken
absolutely what now needs to happen in
order to restore trust in our police
so what should happen who should be held
accountable responsible for the misogyny
and murderous behavior of a police
officer that was formerly part of the
met
okay good question we published a report
two weeks ago looking at the way in
which violence against women and girls
is dealt with as a society and within
policing
and we were very clear that this now
needs to be uplifted as an absolute
priority no longer can crimes against
women and girls be treated as second
rate as not important and in order to do
that we've called on the government to
make it clear to police and crime
commission commissioners and chief
constables that this needs to be treated
in the top three priorities of all crime
that the police deal with and until
there's that leadership that says
unequivocally and clearly two police
officers this is important this is your
principal primary role we're going to
struggle to tackle some of those
cultural issues that we're talking about
today
okay former met um chief super palm
sundew saying yesterday that female
officers don't always report suspicious
behavior of male colleagues because they
close ranks and you risk being left to
get your head kicked in on duty if you
call for help let me just play this grab
to you
if a female officer in particular makes
a a an allegation against a male officer
that allegation will follow her for the
rest of her career if she makes an
allegation and then she has to press the
emergency button for help at a later
date her team may not respond because
teams tend to close ranks there isn't
that sort of um culture where you can
actually bring concerns to the fore and
senior management don't don't always
want to hear those concerns
i did put that to a former uh a friend
of mine who's a former police officer
who also said that that is something
that she recognized what sort of culture
oversees that
okay i know palm really well she used to
work with me uh i hear the authenticity
uh
and what she's saying there um i i hear
two
accounts of women in policing not
feeling that they can speak out but i
hear
an overwhelming majority now of police
officers male and female who are
standing together
they are not accepting of the position
that they find themselves in they're
standing together to call out these uh
these heinous acts but also these small
microcosms of behaviors that we know
will lead to escalations of behaviors on
the part of police officers and we now
need to keep create the culture and
environment where people are not only
supportive they're act actively actively
encouraged to step forward and step out
i've worked for 12 years kay
in policing
police has been betrayed by this monster
but i am absolutely certain that there
are
hundreds of thousands of police officers
up and down the land who get up every
morning to do nothing but to serve the
public to do the right thing and it's
those police officers that we need to be
focusing on today and encouraging them
to stand together and to call this out